largas condenas de prisión y hasta la
pena de muerte son las consecuencias que
pueden afrontar aquellas personas que
sean juzgadas bajo el delito de
homosexualidad en uganda el presidente
jowbery musevini firmó una ley que prevé
fuertes castigos para las relaciones
sexuales homosexuales y para los que se
atrevan a hablar en público sobre el
tema
si realizas un acto sexual con una
persona del mismo sexo entonces has
cometido el delito de homosexualidad y
cuál es la pena prisión
perpetuamos sexualmente cuando llevas a
cabo actos de homosexualidad a través de
la fuerza entonces la ley Define eso
como homosexualidad agravada y cuál es
la pena la muerte
la ley promulgada por el parlamento
precisa que ser homosexual no es un
delito mantener relaciones sexuales
entre personas del mismo sexo sí la
nueva legislación ha sido condenada por
países occidentales y por el alto
comisionado de Derechos Humanos para la
ONU así como por parte de organizaciones
y activistas ugandeses
no hay esperanza Pero a dónde se supone
que debemos ir no nos quieren en su país
no nos están dando trabajo ni educación
y medicamentos nos están criminalizando
nos están arrestando simplemente por
existir simple
cómo nos convertimos en refugiados no
deseados en nuestro propio país
previo a la aprobación la Casa Blanca
había advertido al gobierno ugandés
posibles consecuencias económicas
mientras que la ley goza de gran apoyo
Popular en este país gobernado con mano
de hierro por llover y musevini desde